what's going on everybody and welcome to
part three of the Python 33.7 to be
specific basics tutorial in this video
what we're going to be doing is starting
our overarching objective for the series
which is to create a text-based version
of tic-tac-toe which should allow us to
cover all the basics we need before we
can get the heck out of the basics and
start doing things that you personally
are interested in so with that let's go
ahead and get started so first of all
right out of the gate we we know what we
want to do we want to make tic-tac-toe
we're gonna simplify it by not making
any sort of graphical user interface
we're going to keep it just text-based
so that the the graphical bit is so we
can see the game and all that will just
happen in the console basically so so
that's all so we're gonna keep it there
but we still have a lot of questions to
answer like you know we know that we
want to make tic-tac-toe I think most of
us know going into tic-tac-toe how the
game works and the rules but how do we
make a program know the rules
and how do we display it just right how
do we take an input from the user to
where they want to play all that stuff
how do we how do we actually do that so
the first thing and honestly this is a
this is these questions or this is how
you approach any problem obviously
tic-tac-toe is a super basic thing but
it forces there's actually a lot of
complex things associated with even just
something as simple as tic-tac-toe so
hopefully this approach to solving the
problem will make sense to you and you
can start to kind of think this way
about any problem so when you've got a
problem you what you have to do is just
break it down into just the mote the
smallest pieces that you can just start
ticking off those small pieces until
finally you've got your finished product
so the first thing we want to do is I'm
just going to go ahead and clear
everything out here and let's just run
that clear it up so so with the game to
play tic-tac-toe we need to play it on
something we need some sort of game
visual you know
game map so to speak so to do that how
do we want to actually visualize the
game itself so we could do something
like you know somehow visualize a bunch
of emptiness and then you know or maybe
make the grids like so obviously if you
were to draw tic-tac-toe it's like two
lines and then two lines that's gonna be
kind of hard we would spend a lot of
time with the whole ASCII stuff just
getting everything to line up just right
and depending on which editor someone
uses or which consoles someone's using
or what their font is that could get
hairy really quickly so don't really
think I want to do that necessarily so
let's just keep it unbelievably basic so
let's say let's just say we we're gonna
work with zeros ones and twos so zeros
will be just the game map so also just a
thing to note later on when like we're
gonna do things in terms of just using
numbers but later if you want it and I
totally if anybody is like man that's
lame I wanted the two lines if that's
you what you should do is when we're
done here add the two lines to the
representation because it's totally
possible it's just not necessary but
later you can convert everything you can
convert zeros to be spaces then you
could convert you know the ones and twos
to actually be X's and O's and then you
could convert every you know all the
things in between you could use logic to
create the two lines and stuff so I
definitely encourage anybody who wants
to to take that extra step so to start
we're going to just use lists and we're
going to use a list of lists to
represent our game board and to to
process all of our logic because at the
end of the day programming likes to
understand numbers not so much the
visual representation as we go on we
could we can learn to do things like
image processing and image analysis and
even machine learning and stuff to to
learn what a you know visually a
tic-tac-toe map means but chances are
you're not looking to get that complex
here we're just trying to learn the
basics so so let's get started so let's
just say we've got a game so I'm gonna
do the game variable here and we're
going to say game equals and then
we could make it a tuple right so we
could say zero zero zero so we could do
something like that right and then maybe
come down and then somehow like kind of
cheat our way through here and zero zero
zero and don't forget this comma that
would be a syntax error
yikes so we could try to do something
like that but even that's gonna be a
problem at least without our parentheses
so we could continue like this so let's
just copy in paste now what would be the
issue with our game like this because we
could print game now there's gonna be
two major issues one you should know out
of the gate immediately as we talked
about in the last tutorial but there's
actually two issues let's print it out
and the second issue is going to be
glaring here's the second issue the game
isn't represented like this it's
represented in just a flat because that
newline is just white space it doesn't
mean anything to our programming
language unless it's a code block so so
right now it's just a what we would call
them programming just it's just a flat
tuple here so so what could we do but
also it's a tuple so it's immutable we
can't change it over time so we don't
want that so then what we'd have to do
is like do some redefinition and stuff
it would be just a huge mess so instead
we're going to use lists so we can
convert this to a list really simply
from parentheses to square braces here
boom now it's a list we can run that
again we see okay it's a list we can
even run type game and we'll see ah it's
a list so but the problem is of course
we have the issue of it's all flat when
we try to display it an event we still
want people to at least understand
what's happening in the game so I'm
gonna instead convert this to a list of
lists so now we've got this first row
and now we've got the second row
and then we'll add a third row that's
getting angry because we don't have a
bracket here done now if we were to
print game we can see here okay they're
separated but they're still they're not
they're not like our new line so what
could we do to solve that problem what
we learned it in the last tutorial we
can just iterate over game to display it
all pretty like so what we could say is
four four row in game prints row and now
let me remove game here since that made
it kind of confusing and now that's
starting to look like a 3x3 grid that we
could begin to place things on and all
that so so now we're starting to see
okay the game map is coming together now
let's say you're a user and you wanted
to play on this game map the next thing
that we have to do is figure out how can
we get people to actually say okay I
want to play this spot here because
again like I said in the very beginning
you know I always thought all programs
were these graphical user interfaces but
in reality they're not and so without
getting some pretty complex code we're
not gonna get like a mouse that we're
gonna be like I want to move here and so
we need to let the user input in some
way where do they want to go but in
order to do that the user has to know
okay what do I call this
so in general we might have like some
numbers or some letters and those say I
want to move to 1a or something like
that and as long as we do something like
that we can keep it totally text-based
so in the next tutorial that's what
we're gonna start working on is okay we
know how to iterate over this but now
how do we like as we iterate just
represent and show you know 0 1 2 and
ABC or something like that so the user
could just easily type in okay I want to
move to such-and-such location and then
we could process that and
actually you know make a mark there and
begin to analyze did they make a you
know fully diagonal or horizontal or
vertical and all that so anyways that's
what we're gonna do in the next tutorial
questions comments concerns leaving
below or join the discord otherwise I
will see you guys in another video